and there is a problem in the system
what you do then
if you don't get the right answer and
this is the challenge and the customer
is speaking on our behalf he says listen
if i could ask a christmas present
this is what i want this is exactly what
i wanted
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring upwards labs and hillel at
stanford knowledge is quickly becoming
the most sought after mysterious piece
of the technology puzzle
that we're still unraveling it often
takes a lot of deep technology a lot of
focus
and a lot of unanswered questions to get
to something meaningful
meet segal yahoo the ceo of kms
lighthouse
a global leader in knowledge management
software over the last four years he
managed to take kms from a small
boutique startup to a company that
serves fortune 500 global brands
sagi has extensive knowledge in building
and scaling up businesses and starting
new innovations
he established the international
business division of israel iit giant
amman group from xero
more than 15 years ago and has managed
to grow the business year over year
sagi worked at kpmg in the high-tech
group assisting startups in fundraising
and go to market plans he also holds a
ba in business administration
and mba from the college of management
and is a certified accountant
sege liao welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm good welcome thank you for inviting
me
yeah very very welcome to be here uh
where in israel are you right now
where are you calling from i'm i'm
calling for mohammed ghan
from ramadagan wonderful okay so we're
just on the border of tel aviv
it's really on the border of tel aviv
not fare away from
the central park of tel aviv so i'm
really watching from
the window the central park of tel aviv
that's beautiful and and so
we're definitely not not too far away
and what i'm excited to talk about with
you in these 20 minutes is the is the
whole idea of knowledge management and
what is what does knowledge actually
mean in both in the context of your
previous roles
uh whether whether it's as a vp
international business from on computers
or corporate finance for kpmg
but today the ceo of kms lighthouse and
over the past
almost five years growing it from a
small boutique startup to
to a large company that is uh that is
working and providing solutions for
fortune 500
companies and so take me back you know
perhaps a little bit to your childhood
tell me a little bit about
what what does knowledge mean to you and
how do you find your childhood resonate
with
with this passion that you have today
for knowledge management
so first of all knowledge management as
a child you don't call it knowledge
management
you go to school you study and
everything that you study
and you want to consume it this is
knowledge and um
you don't even understand it until you
get adult and you use it on your
day-to-day at work
so i'm not sure that knowledge
management means a lot as a child
for me but knowledge management is your
ability
uh to to get the information that you
need when you need
it so think about google google is uh
something
think what you do without google let's
ask it differently what you would do
without google right
i'm not sure you can do much in life you
know you are depending you look forward
to
that anymore anything anything you go to
google so knowledge management
is knowledge that google doesn't have
it's a knowledge that exists
in people's brain it's knowledge that
exists in a
business that uh its procedures
processes
definitions and things of this nature
that when you are
as a business and you need to provide
service or to get the knowledge right
you need it now and you want the local
google to work for you and this is
knowledge management
and it sounds like a simple but think
about yourself how much time in your day
you look for information as part of your
day-to-day work
anything you know think about it for a
second anything
so by the way gartner idc a forester
estimate that an employee spend one hour
a day
looking for information and this is
knowledge management
one hour a day you spend just to get
something right
um and there are multiple ways so you
know even
even before we dive into the importance
of it
or or how you how you resolve it
why is it so difficult what is it about
this idea of knowledge and
answering those questions because what
you're describing here is not just the
idea of
how do we you know keep knowledge but
also how do you provide it with a short
sla
and and provide the you know the the
answers you're looking for in the
minimum amount of time
yeah so uh um the way to um
to get knowledge is by training training
and education
so take example of the the simplest
business
call center a teleco provider at t
uh they have a new agent this new agent
start to get calls
and they get this request i want to
upgrade my package i have a problem
think about this use case and now it's a
new agent
you need to respond to a case you want
to close the case and you want to
respond right
so there are multiple ways to address it
one way
you learn everything by heart the other
way you give him a platform that he can
ask a human question
how do i do this and that but what's the
way to upgrade the platform
or to upgrade the service and get the
answer and this
is uh it sounds like easy but this is a
challenge and
the technology in this market exists for
the last 20 years
or so but in my opinion it didn't have
ai
and other technologies that arrive in
the last
four to five years in more advanced
solutions and this is the reason that
there is now a a a new uh
a new enrollment of new technologies
trying to overcome
a problem that exists over the last 20
30 years
an ai for example if you take ai
as a technology that enable us to
predict enable us to understand enable
us to
to get intent you know it stands for the
the intent of the person
this is a technology that changing the
way you consume knowledge
instead of learning so instead of
learning everything by heart and trying
to remember
each situation what you do you are
asking a question
and the engine works for you and this is
uh
what we are bringing in kms sliders to
the table a new technology
that is actually resolving a problem
that exists for many many years
now that all that makes a lot of sense
to me so walk me through
you know the last five years or so
what's what's actually been happening
why do you decide to focus your time on
on this
issue which by now i'm convinced to ask
to that question but then
how do you go about resolving it how do
you go about saying okay i have a
differentiator here
and the way that i'm approaching this is
a little bit different than than
everybody else
so it starts uh with um first of all
understanding there is a problem so you
you stick with customers you learn
what challenges you they have you learn
what processes they have in order to
bring new employees
you understand how where is the
information resistant you know where
it's sitting
inside the organization and during those
discussions and calls
you figure out that the problem is huge
because there are multiple folders
multiple uh
domains multiple you know people
it's it's really a massive uh massive uh
information that currently is really
distributed in silos
and for each problem it's uh they have a
different system
so i will uh give you an example a bank
will have a system that supports uh
employees regular employees on day to
day it will be one system will be
different system
for agents will be different system for
bankers in the branch
and will be different systems that
support customers when they go online
so think what a challenge you know
multiple system
multiple people different skill set by
the way not a
an agent is not uh someone like i don't
know a manager someone that manager bank
but someone that manager bank also need
the information
and we figure out that there isn't a
single system
that is enterprise-wide you know there's
a lot of small solutions for each
problem for agents i'm telling you that
the system
for bankers in the branch they had
something that enabled the bankers to do
their job better
self-service by the way if you look for
self-service
don't look uh look today you know now we
are moving a real digital transformation
before coffee what is self-service no
one had any clue what is self-service
in a good setup you had two free
questions in faq you know it wasn't
really self-service so all those
challenges are coming together
and it's enterprise you want a system
with authorization you want each person
to see what he's allowed to see
you want each person you get different
answer but so if you are a
internal employee you want to get a
certain answer if you are external
customer
maybe different answer maybe the
marketing need to write the answer
so you don't have any complaint later on
so and this
is when i went to speak with customers
i figured out they have a huge problem
and and this is how we started so we
we understand the challenge we
understand the problem and then we start
to work with our customers and then we
said
how we can make your life better in
terms of knowledge management
and and this is how we start the journey
and you know the real story is
a customer of us it's a mizrahi bank is
one of the largest bank in israel
they had several agents that moved to
the branches
and the agent said why we don't have
lighthouse in the branch why is an agent
in the call center at the system why now
i've been asked the same questions
why don't have the system and this is
how we get to understand that the
problem is
is is enterprise wide it's not a silo
right no and it sounds to me also that
this bottom-up approach of
providing the value to the to the people
that are actually asking these questions
because i'm assuming that
traditionally you know you can obviously
go top down but if you're
but the real pain that you're solving is
for the people that are working hard to
find those answers so when a manager
asks a question
and it takes a few hours to answer and
the person that is you know really
hurting with those few hours of the
people that are looking for the answers
oftentimes i'm imagining the managers
aren't even aware
of the complexity that goes beyond
behind
those infinite infinitely small
decision-making
points in the day-to-day of the
employees right exactly
exactly now
why why are you in this why are you so
excited about
about about knowledge management about
what you're doing here
what what is it about it that says this
is the problem that i choose to solve
first of all again i think it's a it's a
huge problem i think the market
i don't think analyst said the market is
uh billions of dollars
and again the solutions that are over
there for me they are dinosaurs
and it's not a joke go for the largest
bank in the u.s
go to the largest insurance company in
the uk we are working with those guys
it's green system you know the it's like
mainframes it's like s 400 in certain
cases
it's it's a systems that are not
friendly
the search is not advanced uh um the
question that you are asking you need to
know to know exactly what you look for
you need to ask insurance number this
and that oh
you need to unders exactly what you look
for and they claim
it's not friendly we need to train the
agent how to search why you need someone
to train how to search
in google think that now in google
before you go to google i'll tell you
listen
i need to give you a course of one month
to teach you how to search in google
you will love so this exists in
enterprises we are
overcoming something that the search is
there
but it's totally not friendly and they
want to move to the
next generation and we are providing the
next generation and again
it's not only search it's decision flows
uh it said because certain answers it's
not a pure search uh there is a solution
if you are a i don't know credit card if
you are a student there is a different
credit card if you are employed you are
not employed
if you are retired so they need to have
a decision flows that take them a flow
by flow
in order to provide the uh the right
answer i can tell you uh
a customer of us g healthcare older mri
all the
big system machines and being now uh the
call center
uh that is supporting those use cases is
being
powered by kms lighthouse and listen
before the data system but the problem
was to find information when you need it
and now think that you schedule
right an appointment to get
unfortunately an mri
and there is a problem in the system
what you do then
if you don't get the right answer and
this is the challenge and the customer
is speaking on our behalf he says listen
if i could ask a christmas present
this is what i want this is exactly what
i wanted so um
the market is there but it's different
you know we are
reinventing a market that exists for
many years
but in totally different way
so what i'm hearing across the theme
here over the past
13 minutes or so is this a constant
validation that
on one hand you know that this
validation exists because this is not a
new market you're you're
re reinventing the way that we're
thinking about these solutions but the
problem has been there for a long time
with
with what i hear partial solutions and
what i'm also hearing from you is that
the real breakthrough that we've had
over the past five years is through
these new technologies
we're able to not just index the data
and maintain it
which i guess answers the question from
right before we started recording
but it allows us to manage it and it
allows us to resolve to to respond to it
quickly
and and obviously i'm sure that as a
founder and ceo
you you you have some some great sense
of satisfaction
when you have an exec from ge come and
say listen
you know without without these uh
without this technology we wouldn't be
able to answer a lot of the questions
we're answering
this is exactly the case so um i'm very
passionate
about what we do uh i think that uh
you know i'm meeting a lot of customers
by the way pandemic was good for us as a
company
not as a personal you know we are
struggling and hopefully
we can book the first vacation quickly
in the near future pandemic was good for
us now
think about everything i just described
but now you need everybody to send home
okay so before that you had a
let's say a call center 3 thousand
people sitting in the room
and they can ask a question one each
other you can scream to each other yes
they can scream on each other that's
it now he is at home and probably i
don't know even
where exactly is it or maybe he's in a
coffee place or
i don't know exactly and he's the bank
now
someone is calling him he need to
resolve the problem he cannot advise he
cannot ask anyone what to do
and that's it we need to resolve it so
this is this has created for us a
a huge market opportunity um you know uh
fortune 500 companies um speaking to us
incoming calls saying how we can resolve
this because they understand that the
world
before pandemic and after pandemic it's
different
uh the employment will be different we
are speaking everybody now speaking
about hybrid
employment you know i read the workspace
no one is going
speaking that's it it's done we are
behind it and we've been
back you you right you don't imagine now
that everybody will
be back in the same place things are
moving
and this move remove the opportunity to
train
it's difficult to train by the way i
spoke with aig the customer of us
and asking what was the impact of us in
the pandemic and she says listen
i don't know how i could even recruit a
new employees
without your system i interviewed them
by zoom
and they start the first day at home and
you say welcome to world
that's it the life has changed and when
the life change you need to come with a
new technology you need to come with a
new offering
you cannot train as you trained before
you cannot support physically even the
employee as
as you support before by the way in our
system we are also putting uh
the employee in the center he has his
picture he's a
favorite things he can keep he is he
feels someone care for him it's not just
that you give him a pla a place to
search
he feels in the center he can provide
feedback
uh the system will understand where the
feedback is coming from so
he's becoming the center of the
organization even though
he's distributed and this is the the new
reality
uh i think that it's very very timely
that we're that we're having this
conversation obviously and i think that
what you're doing there is
it's really cool in in every sense of
the word just this idea of
you know thinking about how you know
obviously it had a big impact on
companies before
uh pre-code post covered we can only
imagine you know the the
independence the autonomy that you're
providing and that you're
allowing employees to to take i think
that's really the big impact from what
i'm hearing here
what it sounds to me that you know a lot
of these questions were answerable
before
but now you're providing a level of
autonomy that was previously
you know desired today it's mandated
today it is a part of who we are and
there is no going back
so again we don't have much time
unfortunately and and i
but i really want to hear the story of
washing of about purchasing your first
car
and then i have some of my own fun
questions at the end
so you asked me to provide something
funny but since i was a small
child first of all i'm very energized
i i'm always in a move but
since i was a small child i i wanted to
have a car
and uh starting the age at 12 or 13 i
start to wash cars in my neighborhood
and and people start you know to to
invite me to wash their cars
and by the age of 17 i had enough money
to buy my
first gun and uh i think this is again
incredible
yeah this is something special because a
child on the age of 12
13 thinking about the car and working
how to get uh
is the first car it's something special
so because you asked for something funny
i said you know maybe this is
something nice to share with everybody i
love it okay
sagi are you ready for some fun quick
questions for the end yeah sure
all right we'll go from easy to hard
number one what was
one of your favorite subjects in school
from kindergarten
up until high school it's easy
mathematics i love mathematics i'm a
i always enjoy this is probably the the
only thing i love to do i was
uh by the way i was very good in it this
is probably why
i love it and uh it's very simple
or maybe the other way around exactly
exactly but this is a very simple
question
i i love the simplicity of it
one of your role models real or fake so
i think i like to watch a denzel
washington
i don't know if you had um he's speaking
about leadership i
love denzel yeah you know i i saw it
several times by the way the same video
i can see several times and he's
speaking about
the fact that if you fall you fall
forward you never fall back
and i really uh i feel like that you
know even if you lose a deal
you lose an opportunity forget about it
you know don't do good cause analysis
you know in your stomach you understand
why you lost it always think about
the good thing what is left on the table
and focus on the places you are about to
win
winning this is what you need to focus
and if you lost
at least you played the game you you
understand what you did
probably uh don't spend too much uh you
know uh
outing yourself focusing you know on the
next win and that's it and this is i
think uh
something i don't know denzel washington
uh personally but when i
listen to him this is i think the the
model this is uh
his speech looks
three words you would use to describe
yourself i'm always this
smiling energy and winning
uh every almost every as i finish it's
let's win
and i'm always smiling people ask me how
you're smiling all the time
i'm smiling that's it i don't know it's
part of my body
i feel like i need to i'm smiling so
smile
and the winning it's something that uh
if you go to my linkedin
any place you feel it you feel this vibe
uh so
um i love it and and i think coupled
with the smiling and with the energizing
and it makes perfect sense zagee thank
you very very much stay safe and stay
healthy thank you for coming thank you
thank you very much michael and it was
really pleasure it was very fast 20
minutes you said
i feel it it's unbelievable so thank you
i'm looking forward to see you again
that's how i feel every time thank you
very very much take care
[Music]
bye